Olalalalala le plus mignon ! Le plus mignon ! Mais qu'il est mignon ! Oui ! Lèche moi l'oreille [gémissements bizarres]
Si vous pouvez oublier ce qu'il vient de se passer ce serait cool...
Les amis ! Je me suis souvenu y'a pas longtemps que moi quand j'étais jeune,
j'avais envie de raconter des trucs alors j'avais rien à raconter parce que j'avais une vie
vraiment basique de mecs de 15 ans on fait pas des trucs de ouf quand on a 15 ans
Je me suis souvenu y'a pas longtemps
que j'avais créé une chaîne secondaire à l'époque, une chaîne qui s'appelle 'SqueezieAndCie'
la dernière vidéo date d'il y a cinq ans mon gars !
Çaaaaaaaaaaa c'est une chaîne active !!! [tremblements de tête hyperactifs]
Alors, je me souviens que j'avais créé cette chaîne
pour faire ce que j'osais pas faire sur ma chaîne principale
à savoir des petits vlogs qui n'avaient aucun intérêt
et tester des trucs des fois
voilà ça m'amusait
alors aujourd'hui on va regarder les vidéos de cette chaîne là
j'ai com-plè-tement oublié
chaque vidéo c'est incroyable je n'ai aucun souvenir de ce que j'ai pu faire sur cette chaîne
et je vois les miniatures je vous avoue
et ça me fait un peu peur quoi
déjà je me souviens, il y a un truc que je me souviens par contre j'avoue, cette image regardez bien
oui c'est ce que vous croyez.
Vous avez 15 ans vous voulez faire une photo un peu stylée, prenez une putain d'allogène
et mettez- là vous dans la gueule, et faites ce geste avec votre main,
là vous avez un maximum de style !
première vidéo de la chaîne
'ouverture de la chaîne' alors c'est quoi cette chaîne squeezie dit nous on veut savoir
[squeezie jeûne] 'yo tout le monde c'est squeezie
et on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour la présentation de ma 'back up' chanel'
EH ATTENDS !!!!
j'étais plus shtock que maintenant [rires nerveux]
ça fait mal ! regardez le biceps bro qu'est-ce qui s'est passé entre temps là
[Music dénonciatrice que squeezie bouffe mal]
Dans mon cas j'vais upload plein de vidéos dans la vraie vie et aussi des fois des
[Oh putain il a freezé] moments de jeux et aussi,  quelques
moments de jeu et quelques trucs épiques qui me sont arrivées dans les jeux
c'est drôle, j'adore
Mec y a...
j'ai tellement de remarques à faire ça se voit tellement que je suis pas du tout à l'aise quand je fais des respirations et de regard
dans le vide et juste après je fais un mouvement avec mon corps pour montrer "non non je suis à l'aise regardez"
et je suis sûr que le freeze là ce n'était même pas prévu c'est juste je savais plus quoi dire et du coup je m'étais
bloqués comme un con genre vrai réflexe nul
[Bruits de grillons, homme qui tousse]
Bref quoiqu'il en soit je vais commencer par me présenter parce que il y en a peut-être certains d'entre vous ou certaines qui ne savent pas qui je suis
ça c'est vrai "prénom : lucas, pseudonyme internet : squeezie"
cet homme fait des vidéos sur internet qui sont plutôt hilarantes c'est pour ça qu'il a un peu de succès" ouais j'avais déjà de l'ego
Je m'aimais déjà c'est fou ! Je voulais faire c'était comme dans un jeu vidéo quand tu choisis ton perso qui tourne sur lui-même mais
en vrai je marchais vraiment quoi j'étais vraiment en train de tourner sur moi même dans ma chambre
"chausse du 42, fait environ 1m68 âge-"
mec j'ai pris 2 cm en 6 ans
à ce moment de la vidéo squeezie réalise qu'il a été petit toute sa vie, qu'il attend de grandir depuis près de
six ans et que ce n'est jamais arrivé. Il remet alors en question toute sa vie, sa carrière, ses amis, son chien
"ça variera mais en tout cas j'uploaderai beaucoup plus de vidéos que sur ma chaîne principale
car il n'y aura pas de montage à faire ou presque ce sera des vidéos brutes prise avec mon super téléphone portable"
[agaçant] Ben moi j'ai un téléphone fixe
"Mais tu vas la fermer toi bordel de [bip]
Abonnez vous dès maintenant
Alors est-ce que je l'ai fait la vidéo tous les deux jours où est ce que j'ai fait une antoine daniel 12 octobre 12 octobre
12 octobre 12 octobre j'ai mis quatre vidéos en un jour mon pote !
13, 14 mais gros on n'a jamais vu un gars si régulier 15 mais oui !
alors quand squeeze se met au fade shot c'est quoi les fade shot j'ai oublié bonjour. Ah j'ai eu mon heure call of duty
est-ce que j'étais bon ou pas?
C'est tellement le vieux game youtube ça c'est tellement le vieux gamme youtube tu sais
C'est nuuul j'étais déjà pourri aux jeux !  Vu qu'au début en fait j'uploadais juste des petits clips de j- de jeux vidéos quoi
des clips où je me trouvais stylé regardez où je modifiais les couleurs comme un bâtard donc je voulais faire comme les gens stylé de
de l'époque comme diablox9 Wartek et tout sauf que moi j'étais nul ! Oh une vidéo regardez regardez ya six ans merci à tous mes
abonnés ouais c'est vrai qu'y a six ans je pensais déjà à vous je pensais pas à consulter un bescherelle par contre ça c'est clair et
net, salut tout le monde c'est Squeezie Oh la musique émouvante
petite vidéo très courte
pour remercier
mes 107 abonnés parce que c'est vraiment énorme non vraiment c'est vraiment je trouve ça vraiment sympa de votre part... Oh bah tient !
mais en 2011 ça gratte déjà des j'aimes sur les vidéos !
Amixem t'as rien inventé regardes le vrai vendeur de tapis c'est qui c'est Lulu !  Double click sur j'aime pour cette blague
doubleclick manque pas un clic simple double-clic gros gaillard bug ou revas pont pour tous vos commentaires vos conseils vos idées vos
mails vos fins tout ça quoi
c'est drôle parce que je me souviens quand j'avais 107 abonnés y en avait 35 c'étaient des amis et les 78
il m'envoyait vraiment pas de mails où il mettait vraiment très de commentaires sur les vidéos georges fait le gros mytho au genre je reçois
trop d'amour et tous merci je suis touchée alors qu'en vrai je recevais vraiment rien
j'étais obligée d un truc aux mondieux le premier blog une maison très design
je crois que la qualité est là chier on va pouvoir regarder et on se retrouve tout redécouvrir la nuque à trois 2 1 go
let go
Je n'ai plus d'oreilles c'est bon mais menace se faisait marrer ça la soul et
Regarder tout ce qui est bien chez moi il vous avait pas car vos parents sont moins riches que les miens
c'est horrible on va je trouve je découvrais pour la première fois le frigo américain de ceux qui envoient de la glace et tout est
du coup j'ai trouvé ça ou fait du coup j'avais fait une vidéo
il en fallait peu pour faire une vidéo à l'époque mais je sois que ça m'amusait beaucoup à cette machine a
Donc il ya vraiment y'a vraiment j'ai des glaçons que devant un verre on est d'accord et je rigole énormément
oh putain la caméra hd y as you tout le monde si squeeze
aujourd'hui pour une nouvelle vidéo
chez mon père ça ça c'est le long couloir tu mon père dans lequel il fut chef sylvain mille fois parce que j'avais extrêmement peur
je voulais juste vous dire que en fait il se trouve que la caméra hd elle est dans la poche place des messieurs
non plus sérieusement mon père a accepté de me la donner dès maintenant
donc vous pouvez tous dire merci le padre de tout cas parce qu'ils ont commencé papa
je vais pouvoir avoir 10 millions d'abonnés rejouerez vivent de ce que j'aime
merci papa voilà hélas dams et messieurs j'ai une technique pour percer dans rien
Que celui-ci
bien vous avez cliqué maintenant c'est tout oui ne fait pas ça déjà à l'époque
j'influencé mal la jeunesse c'est bien bravo Lucas
faite des petits trous comme ça
et ça fait pas de bruit et c'est beaucoup mieux
ah oui c'est vrai à chaque midi c'est comme ça moi que je fais
alors on est d'accord le blog c'est juste dire j'ai une caméra hd et je mets un plat au micro ondes
On est bien d'accord ?
je vais aller tourner la vidéo que je mettrai en ligne lorsque j'aurai 10000 abonnés la vidéo de présentation
donc j'aime casser le cul encore à faire des vidéos alors que la chante d'une dissertation
Ohlala le gars il se plaint, il se plaint le gars il fait des vidéos il se plaint déjà quoi
excusez moi si j'ai une voix bizarre c'est parce que je voulais vous dire que je suis malade
Euhh..
et je trouve ça ...
ne me dis pas que je vais chanter la chanson je suis malade j'espère vraiment pas
Euhh, je disais que je trouve ça un peu bête d'être malade à ce stade-là
parce-que je dois atteindre les 10000 abonnés et je devais faire une vidéo ce soir
Le mec il est déprimé
C'est horrible d'être malade à ce stade là d'abonnés c'est chiant d'être malade tout court Lucas on s'en bats les couilles de ton nombre d'abonnés
Enfin bref, avec une voix comme ça, ça sera pas top donc j'espère
Je fais que me plaindre en faite
dans mes blogs je faisais que de me plaindre c'est vrai depuis tout à l'heure je me plains gros c'est dingue, ahh ahh j'ai jamais fait ensuite
en attendant les 10000 à tous et là on enchaîne là là on enchaîne donc les 10000 ça fait
ça fait six vidéos que j'en parle quoi gens c'est vraiment une obsession c'était maladif, regarder le smile
le gars il sait qu'il est proche des 10000, il pense qu'à ça en fait j'ai également parlé des 10000 parce que je me souviens que
je m'étais donné de fou pour les 10000 abonnés j'avais fait un truc de
présentation est en fait à la fin je dansais tu avais le choix entre plusieurs vidéos il y avait six vidéos gros est mec je
m'était donné mon pote, c'est pour ça que je fais que d'en parler c'est que j'en avais chié je crois
alléluia au putain qu'est ce qui c'est passé là, un peu de joie là, euhh c'est à dire que je vais chez le coiffeur
Haha
dans 20 minutes j'y vais fin...
*Rire*
Vous comprenez pourquoi j'ai eu des problèmes capillaires pendant si longtemps
j'allais chez le coiffeur une fois tous les cinq mois mon gars étaient si rares que quand j allais je faisais une vidéo avant pour
dire à quel point j'étais heureux vous rendez compte de ça alors maintenant je vais toutes les semaines ok je prends ma vengeance sur la vie
Ca va me faire du bien de couper de raser la touffe
Euhh...
donc dans un instant je vois un petit montage vidéo vous verrez que les cheveux coupés on veut on veut voir j'ai intérêt à assurer au montage
3 2 1
Et...
Et voilà, nan sans rire les gens
Je reviens de chez le coiffeur et regardé
bon ça va c'est mieux que d'habitude on va pas se mentir même si la saf un truc chez nous mais mec c'est normal j'ai jamais
chez le coiffeur
tu as vu la cour qui me fait comme j'y vais gros c'est hyper grave, rembourse moi si tu regarde cette vidéo t'as pas honte
une entrée hépic à bas on veut la voir
Yo tout le monde c'est squeezie
*Musique*
Lucas quand tu écoute de la musique fort quitte ambiance énormément ce qui se passe dans ta tête tu ne peux pas leur transmettre à
la caméra on voit juste un petit enfant pas très stylé qui danse mal sur une musique pas ouf
des gens ne vont pas ressentir ce que tu ressens, Ok ?
Ok sans rire, alors pourquoi je fais cette petite vidéo, je vais baisser le son un petit peu
Mais quelle ambiance
Parce que ma mère va me nuque et ça je le dis pas ça bah non
*Musique*
Une petite exclu pour vous au bas c'est quoi l'exclu tiens ça doit être un truc incroyable ça
J'ai bien bosser sur les vidéos en ce moment et j'ai même changé une lumière pour que ça fasse une lumière plus agréable dans la
vidéo
non c'est faux comme quand tu es à ado ce besoin de
dire tout ce qui me passe par la tête tu vois quand on grandit on arrive à se canaliser et là vraiment dès que j'ai un
une micro idée qui me passe par la tête, je suis obligé et de la dire tout de suite je viens de me souvenir de ce à
quoi tu as besoin de tout excès reese et que tu vois un truc tu dois te dire au toit fermé en tout cas jeté
comme ça c'était journée d'un geek c'était musique que je faisais avec fait durer l'époque à voilà les laisse
anciens
reconnaîtront c'est génial c'était mes potes du lycée un groupe qui me cadrer à ce moment là on s'est beaucoup de trucs ensemble avec antoine
et florent il s'appelait ses rangs un moyen de se taper des bonnes barres
ensemble et de créer des trucs en même temps et en visitant content de ça je trouve qu'on entend c'est d'être au bon souvenir quoi
les chansons sans eux j'aurais pas pu les faire par exemple j'ai eu beaucoup de chance d'avoir un entourage à l'époque de potes qui comprenait
ce que je faisais et qu'ils joignent aux délires et ça les faisait qui fait isolé et il était par moddy's braqué il trouve c'est
la honte c'était tout l'inversé quoi donc c'était vraiment sympa
Il a un peu saoulé mon pote il est un peu saoul et je le fais chier c'est bien là non comme ça plus et
donc ça ça avait donné donc c'est déjà de bêtisiers de journée d'un gi qui était le premier gros boss de mme hachem
onana la première au plus tard tu stomisés vos manettes pour pas cher mais qu'est ce qui se passe
je vous parle de cette chaîne donne simplement parce que le directeur est sympa
C'était y avait un gars qui avait une bois et a contacté m à 12 15 ans sur net en lui disant est ce qu'on
fait c'est génial c'est vraiment top me suis même avait mis la pression pour que cette vidéo quoi c'est parce que les prix sont
bas je vois là là
vous imaginez je fais ça maintenant vous agir discours comme ça maintenant là
pour qu'ils aient
en échange le soleil m'avait juste customiser une manette pour voir ma première hop et du coup en gros j'ai touché 20 euros
c'est bien à propos du cas
bonjour tout le monde s'est tu
aujourd'hui je suis pas là pour vous parler d'un sujet quelconque par exemple
géologie sait pas trop à ça pas toi je suis là pour vous parler de la vidéo j'aime call of
que j'ai dû supprimer car si vous voulez il ya une séquence que pour
un oui je me souviens de cette histoire bon je vous la simple puisque l'aca 4 minutes 20 je vous la fait en 10 secondes
en gros on avait fait un deuxième clip après jamais d'un guide que je ne vous montrez est le deuxième club avait trouvé un marché
sapé j'aime call of sauf qu'à un moment on tapait un numéro et tout le monde s'est amusé à appeler le gars est du coup
le gars m'a appelé moi pour me dire elle supprime ta vidéo parce que tu m'appelles c'est relou et donc j'avais dû la supprimer
foot et numéro l art met en ligne et j'étais dégoûté voilà y avait but ce pack 3 qui l'avait commentée hockey et ça ce
n'est pas rien de mon petit coeur en putain j'ai fait un court métrage un jour gros j'ai fait un court métrage
un jour c'est parti est ce que c'est mais bollywood et on va voir
Entrez!
Hé Lucas, tu me prêtes ton axe?
Non
C'est bon?
Ah ouais...
Wais.
Qu'est-ce que tu vas me faire hein?
Qu'est-ce que tu vas me faire?
J'vais ni**er ta race!
PIF PAF POK KOF etc...
Ah tu m'as ni**é..
Ahh-AIE!
Oh non! j'aurais peut être du lui dire c'était de l'eau de javel dedans
HAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAARGH MES AISSEEEEEEEEEEEEELLLLEEEESSSSSSSS!!!!!!!!!!!! (lol)
Axes franchement si vous voulez je vous vends les droits de ce court métrage pour votre prochaine pub ya aucun problème
contactez moi vous me customiser une manette xbox et je vous lâche la vidéo surprise pour fait ok si j'avais fait chacun
ah oui
J'étais chez les parents du gouffre est à côté de reims pendant deux jours j'ai filmé plein de petits trucs que j'avais fait une petite
vidéo surprise c'est vraiment ce que tu veux quand tu veux pécho une fille normalement vraiment mais j'ai fait pour mon ami c'est très bizarre
Donc j'ai vraiment film est un mec torse nu pendant 10 minutes faire du piano
pour en faire une compil et la m sont hachées de secondaire
Franchement hugo à table à zurich ou des trucs
ouais après y'a rien dit ou fait si j'avais fait dans les t-shirts avec mon frère à
l'époque sur spreadshirt ces t-shirts là il n'existe plus d'ailleurs certains vers chez nous c'est collector vraiment non c'est faux
ça pue mais c'est sympa c'est après une fois que je bosse avec mon frère
du coup c'était à cinq ans alors j'avais 17 ans quoi est il était grave chaud et oui ma vie mais il m'avait fait confiance
sur ce truc là et ça lui avait fait aussi un peu d'argent pour lui puisqu'il avait bossé dur là-dessus c'est vrai on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui c'est lui qu'a fait mal ou trop café l'image de la chaîne la bannière de la chaîne
et là on est en train de bosser sur d'autres trucs j'adore et je les aime très fort florent et la dernière vidéo de la
chaîne c'était au moment de la sortie
du dernier album de daft punk
bon ben voilà il ya un sujet il ya un thème moi je parle d'un truc que j'aime là c'est bien non là c'est bien
là et on y est alors
Au putain merde
Oh le thug il a mis du serpentin sur sa terrasse
wow yo
avec allogènes des amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur ce petit tour de ma chaîne secondaire n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si
elle vous a plu putain mais c'est fou cette gen secondaire j'avais
oublié ce que je raconte est ce que je faisais pourquoi je les fais j'ai tout oublié
c'est génial en tout cas ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que on commence tous par faire des trucs un peu floue un peu bizarre on
n'est pas très doué dans ce qu'on fait et c'est pareil pour tous les milieux je pense un gain qui commença à
dessiner il est pas bon d ça un gars qui ont ce faire la musique bat il est à chier au début c'est normal c'est
comme ça dans tous les milieux
créatifs et j'ai juste envie de vous demander d'être indulgents que vous voyez quelqu'un qu'on est encore à ce stade
de sa carrière
qui est pas très à l'aise qui sait pas trop ce qui fait qu'ils racontent pas grand-chose bah c'est pas grave ça c'est rien de
le bâcher soyons cool avec avec les gens qui en sont au début de leur truc justement au compteur en cours à journée devant
leur de la force en fait c'est impossible d'arriver sur youtube et de tout de suite marché à mort gagner je sais pas combien d'abonnés
faire des vidéos génial
non faut passer par une phase où tu te cherches où tu apprends à faire ce que tu as envie de
faire ou tu prends une direction et je trouve qu'on oublie qu'il ya cette phrase qui et qui pourtant est très importante donc voilà je
vous fais des bisous je quitte cette vidéo en étant très ému je vous dis à bientôt pour un truc un peu plus drôle même
si la c'etait drôle quand même en vrai
je vais me boire un petit café
Natsu il dort tellement biennn
Oh je suis obligé de filmer
Ohhh on quitte la vidéo comme on l'a commencée tiens
regardez il est tellement bien [KAWAII]
Ho Le Bébé ! x2
Mais voui bébéééé
Mais oui bébéééé
[Sous-Titres __ Les gens présent dans la descrîption]